pouvez vous lever non ce qu'elle est
dans un des vrais pour médiévale
épicerie et en même temps on sent
qu'elle bosse aux puces de clignancourt
dira ya vraiment tous les délires c'est
rock mais machine qu'est ce qui s'est
passé j'ai craqué j'ai craqué ce matin
et je me suis dit peut-être pour
l'émission fait dans me1 qu'elle canapé
on est sûr qu'elle m'a d'ailleurs c'est
un peu rideau c'est vrai c'est un peu
rideau mais ça passe je vais pas je
trouve que ça passe pas mal non et on se
doit non mais c'est génial
elle est jolie mais vous les wamiz
mais pas tous
médiéval du vin c'est aussi du je pense
que ça va être la mode d'ici dix ou
quinze ans christophe qui